willkommen zurück WhatsApp ja WhatsApp
ist wieder da allerdings die Aufregung
hierzulande die war natürlich groß denn
zigtausende Menschen in Deutschland
konnten den instant messenger-dienst
über mehrere Stunden gar nicht nutzen
Nachrichten konnten weder versendet noch
empfangen werden das Portal alle
Störungen das zählte hierzulande ja
schon mehr als 200.000 Meldungen von
Betroffenen offenbar ging die Störung
auch über Deutschland hinaus bei Twitter
kommentierten auch zahlreiche Nutzer aus
dem Ausland das nichts ging Gründe für
den Ausfall sind stand jetzt noch keine
bekannt ja aber vielleicht weiß unser
Kollege Martin Eisenlauer da ein
bisschen mehr bei uns im Studio jetzt
Martin also hast du irgendeine Erklärung
dafür was könnte da passiert sein leider
nein es ist normalerweise immer so wenn
es solche Störungen gibt wird zuerst das
Problem behoben und dann guckt man was
ist da eigentlich los gewesen und dann
am Ende wird kommuniziert das heißt
heute Nachmittag wenn wir vielleicht
irgendwann mal erfahren was tatsächlich
los war momentan wissen wir nur es ging
eine Zeit lang nichts und welche
Möglichkeiten gäbe es da warum WhatsApp
auch diesmal ausge drin sein könnte ist
es ja schon des öfteren vorgekommen ja
es wurde irgendwie spekuliert vielleicht
ist ein Internetkabel durchgeschnitten
worden oder so irgendwo vielleicht waren
es mal wieder die Russen aber ich glaube
ehrlich gesagt nicht dran es sieht für
mich wie ein Serverausfall aus weil es
war eben plötzlich alles weg und dann
kam das offensichtlich langsam wieder
und das ist so ein relativ typischer
Verlauf für eben genau dieses Problem
Rechner fällt aus und dann muss man da
hin und den vielleicht auch wieder von
Hand neustarten hatten wir bei Facebook
ja auch schon dass sie dann nicht mehr
ins Rechenzentrum kamen und so sieht das
jetzt momentan für mich aus jetzt fragen
sich natürlich viele Nutzer also wenn
ich da während dieser Zeit kurz vorher
vielleicht eine Nachricht abgeschickt
habe und dann ging plötzlich nichts mehr
geht ihr jetzt irgendwo in das wäre
verloren jetzt habe ich meinem Liebsten
was geschickt und der kriegt das
überhaupt nicht oder kommen die dann
tatsächlich alle irgendwann ein bisschen
was später dann auch wieder an ja die
müssten jetzt eigentlich alle ankommen
weil die Nachricht bleibt auf deinem
Handy bis zu dem Moment wo du sie
schickst das heißt wenn der den Server
nicht erreicht bleibt sie auch da und
der versucht die immer wieder zu
schicken das jetzt auch dazu führen dass
es ein bisschen länger dauert bis die
Server wieder ans Laufen kommen weil da
eben noch so dieser ganze Backlog hinten
dran genau da muss jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen was abgearbeitet werden ja aber
ich glaube das ist eine Sache von naja
höchstens Stunden okay gut gibt es denn
da auch tatsächlich jetzt
wirtschaftliche Konsequenzen für das
Unternehmen man darf ja nicht vergessen
das sind Millionen Nutzer die da jetzt
nichts gemacht haben oder macht das
überhaupt nichts aus naja also die
meisten Leute werden ihre Geschäfte
nicht über WhatsApp machen das ist
hauptsächlich eine private Plattform es
gibt dieses WhatsApp for business klar
das ist dann ärgerlich das Nutzen
hauptsächlich kleine Mittelständler wie
Handwerker um mit ihren Kunden zu
kommunizieren aber die haben
wahrscheinlich angerufen in der Zeit
wenn es tatsächlich dringend war um
Termine abzustimmen oder so insofern
glaube ich ist der wirtschaftliche
Schaden tatsächlich überschaubar zu Maß
jetzt eben auch nur zwei Stunden waren
Martin Eisenlauer Dankeschön für all
diese Erklärungen vielen Dank für deine
Einschätzungen
[Musik]